you know I've had to take a piece in
6:15 you don't hear me whining about it
I'm going to finish up to our next
presenter is the bigger-than-life star
of such blockbusters as the Terminator
Total Recall and True Lies but ladies
and gentlemen to me he'll always be just
my lifting buddy down at the gym please
welcome one of the most popular film
actors on the planet and the only man
named Schwarzenegger ever allowed to
sleep in Ted Kennedy's guest room Arnold
Schwarzenegger
the Aryan Thalberg award honors people
who have devoted their lives to
producing movies of lasting value
it's named after man who presided of a
vast studio during Hollywood's golden
age this year for the first time he goes
to an actor producer a man who presides
over his own very small company in the
last three decades he has made 35 films
through it starting in 33 of them and
directing 20 of them himself
two years ago he won't ask us for Best
Picture and Best Direction it's tempting
to say that over the years he has
created an institution except that these
days there are very few institutions as
widely respected or as affectionately
regarded as the one we know as clean the
Eastwood especially Bernie
he was my boyhood idol and now I'm proud
to say he's my dear friend there very
few filmmakers who have created a body
of work it has given us so much pleasure
or stands up so well
thank you very much thank you thank you
my son was I in Austria 45 years ago
Thank You Arnold this is heavy I got to
tell you you're probably the only guy
who can haul this for me I'd like to
thank the Board of Governors Caribbean
Motion Pictures Arts & Sciences for this
wonderful award you know I look back
through the over the years of the
recipients of this since 1937 I see
Darryl zanuck and the great Hal Wallis
and William Wyler and Billy Wilder and
Alfred Hitchcock and Stephens all these
people that I grew up idolizing they
were my boyhood idol is as far as
filmmakers and a lot of more directors
producers and and just straight
producers and they were experts these
people had a great influence and they
were experts in a business that has very
few experts really in fact if anybody
asked me about making films I would say
that that it's probably a little
expertise and a lot of luck now how I
fit into that equation well if if Dirty
Harry if I was in his sights and he said
do you feel lucky I'd say you're damn
right I do
thank you thank my family
you